[Music]
High School Musical the Disney Channel
movie that started a friggin phenomenon
there were two sequels one of them
getting at theatrical release a hit
soundtrack and even the hit stage play
that came from this kids growing up at
the time were obsessed with this and
being adults we of course rolled her
eyes and set out come on stupid lame
corny bla ba ba ba ba hey if you've seen
my review of High School Musical 3 which
I did several Disney's Emperor's ago
you'll know that I think yeah it is all
those things but it's kind of smart
about it
if that makes sense it's kind of like
our generation Saved by the Bell except
that it knows it's this generation Saved
by the Bell does that mean where it all
started as pure corny gold well let's
take a look Troy Gabrielle are two high
school kids that meet at a New Year's
party they can force him to singing
karaoke together and of course sound
amazing and sure enough it turns out
she's now going to his school oh lucky
lucky they discovered that they
surprisingly liked singing but uh-oh
he's one of the best players on the
basketball team and she's one of the
smartest minds in the science club so
there of course embarrassed when they
think about trying out for the High
School Musical just because they want to
but a incredibly bizarre brother and
sister team Noah Sharpay and Ryan are
always the center of attention in
theatre and thus they want to sabotage
their chances of being stars so they
start telling everybody that they're
trying out for the high school musical
but sure enough everyone starts to get
the idea that maybe they should do what
they really love maybe a skater can
dance maybe a basketball star can make
cookies
oh-ho amad having possibilities on the
surface this all seems well stupid and
yeah it is stupid
it's a playful kind of stupid that makes
it very obvious you're not supposed to
take it bad seriously there's a whole
song all the kids sing about sticking to
the status quo no high school kid would
have that exact mindset but it's kind of
satirizing that mindset while also being
silly about it it's also nice to see
what's most ly a hodgepodge of cliches
break one or two cliches for example
these stories are usually about the
geeky kid trying to fit in and I like
the idea that these kids are already
popular and they want to do something
that's not very popular simply because
they want to as much as we like to make
fun of characters like this like Oh
being popular
where is so hard give it credit that
does show their stress and pressure that
applies to these kind of people to that
pressure of performing that pressure of
being what everybody wants you to be I
also like that the acting teacher is not
your stereotypical inspiring acting
teacher she's actually kind of a bitch
she yells she screams she has really
strict rules it helps break the idea
that this movie has an agenda to get you
into musical theater ironically there's
not much musical theater in it oh not
that there are dance numbers and songs
and such but we don't even know what the
high school musical is about hell then
we can perform the high school musical
all we get up to is the audition part
and yeah when you have characters like
this brother and sister running around
who are just so odd and so in their own
little world you kind of realize this
movies in its own little world too
the one thing that legitimately bothers
me about it is that some of the
characters cheat in order to get what
they want
okay we learned our lesson cheating is
wrong you should never force anything
but then the main characters cheat to
make everything right anyone that knows
anything about sports games or
competition or anything knows that this
is really wrong this really isn't
ethically sound but when you get to the
ending and see just how much everything
wraps up literally in one shot it shows
the epilogues of every character going
super super fast you do realize like the
characters in the movie you're not
supposed to take this stuff that
seriously you're supposed to just have
fun with it so does that mean I like it
um actually I found it a little dull
yeah I know right it sounds like I'm
praising the hell out of it but honestly
it's kind of slow-moving
I like that deals with high school
issues granted in a very corny way but I
surprisingly could have used a few more
energized musical numbers because when
they're just sitting around talking it's
bad but not good either but to be fair
I'm sure that's because I'm an adult
middle school kids hell even high school
kids I'm sure watch this and loved it
and wanted to be the characters in this
and spin around and look pretty and I
don't know it's not my thing but I can't
say it's bad the guy who directed these
movies also directed Newsies which I
didn't like I thought that flamboyant
Broadway style didn't match the world
that they were in here the world
definitely embraces it and if that's
your thing
I
sure you'll have fun it didn't really
grab me but it's not supposed to grab me
it's supposed to grab kids who wanna
sing and dance and look sparkly and
fabulous and maybe have a thing for your
siblings I don't know if I'm the only
one that got a little uncomfortable
sometimes with that I guess I can see
why this took off I mean there is a lot
of talent behind it it's just not the
kind of talent I get into but for those
that do sit back they are surprisingly a
fair amount to appreciate
[Music]
you